Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at PathwaysAlliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在通往净零排放的道路上取得进展。他们投资于技术和创新，已将每桶石油的平均碳排放量降低了22%。他们与政府合作以创造和保护就业机会，并正在建设世界最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 PathwaysAlliance.ca 了解我们付诸实践的计划。
Cindy Paulson stood alone on the corner of East 4th Avenue and Denali Street in downtown Anchorage. 18-year-old Cindy was a sex worker who frequented the city's infamous Tenderloin district. With its array of bars and clubs, the area was typically a hotbed of potential clients. But so far, the night of Sunday June 12 1983 had been a quiet one. Then, shortly before midnight, a green Buick sentry pulled up to the curb where Cindy stood. The male driver peered up at her from behind a pair of thick rimmed eyeglasses. He propositioned Cindy and the pair began negotiating. After they'd settled on a price, Cindy climbed into the car's passenger seat.
辛迪·保尔森独自站在安克雷奇市中心东第四大道和杰纳利街的街角。18岁的辛迪是一名性工作者，经常出没于该市臭名昭著的红灯区。这里有着各种酒吧和俱乐部，通常是潜在客户聚集的热点。但截至1983年6月12日星期日晚，这天晚上一直很安静。接着，就在午夜之前，一辆绿色的别克世纪轿车停在了辛迪站立的路边。男司机透过一副厚框眼镜抬头看着她。他向辛迪搭讪，两人开始谈价钱。在敲定价格后，辛迪坐上了汽车的副驾驶座。
The man drove her to a secluded parking lot and turned off the engine. Within seconds, he'd produced a wood-handled 357 Magnum revolver. Aiming at Cindy with one hand, he grabbed a pair of handcuffs from under his seat with the other. A smile crept across his pockmarked face as he restrained Cindy's wrists. We're going to my house, he told her. He drove east along the Glen Highway where the city's lights and noise were soon replaced by the dark stillness of suburbia. Turning down a cul-de-sac named Old Harbour Avenue, they passed several ranch-like family homes before pulling into a driveway that led to a single story blue-gray weatherboard house.
这名男子把车开到一个偏僻的停车场，并熄了发动机。几秒钟之内，他掏出了一把带木柄的 .357 马格南左轮手枪。他一只手用枪指着辛迪，另一只手从座位底下抓出一副手铐。他的麻脸上露出一丝微笑，同时铐住了辛迪的手腕。我们要去我家，他对她说。他沿着格伦高速公路向东开去，市里的灯光和噪音很快就被郊区黑暗的寂静所取代。驶入一条名为旧港大道的 cul-de-sac（尽头路）后，他们路过了几栋牧场风格的家庭住宅，然后驶入了一条车道，车道通向一栋单层的蓝灰色木瓦平房。
A pair of antlers hung above the door of a two-car garage. To its right was the main living area, with several windows overlooking the front lawn. No one stirred within. The remainder of the spacious property was equally silent and still, shadowed by tall aspen and birch trees. Dragging Cindy inside the house, the man took her down some stairs into a wood-paneled basement. What first caught her attention were all the taxidermied animals and hunting trophies that filled the room. Rainbirds, mountain goats, dull sheep and caribou had been stuffed and mounted throughout.
一对手鹿角挂在一个双车库的门上方。它的右边是主要起居区，有几扇窗户俯瞰着前院。里面毫无动静。这处宽敞房产的其余部分同样寂静无声，在高大的白杨树和桦树的阴影下显得格外安静。这名男子把辛迪拖进屋里，带她顺着楼梯走下一间木质镶板的地下室。首先引起她注意的是填满整个房间的各种动物标本和狩猎战利品。雷鸟、山羊、盘羊和北美驯鹿被制成标本，挂满了整个房间。
Walrus tusks and moose antlers decorated the walls. Beaver and wolf hides were scattered about. On the floor was a baskin rug. In a moment of crystal-clear clarity, Cindy realised that she was trapped in the lair of a man who liked killing. Retrieving a chain, the man wrapped it around Cindy's neck four times before locking it against a wooden support beam. Then he raped her, before settling down for a nap on a nearby sofa. Pointing his revolver at Cindy, he warned her not to wake him or quote, You'll make me mad, and you don't want to see me mad.
海象牙和驼鹿角装饰着墙壁。海狸和狼的皮毛散落各处。地板上铺着一张熊皮地毯。在某一瞬间，辛迪脑海中异常清晰地意识到，自己被困在了一个喜欢杀戮的男子的巢穴里。男子取出一根链条，在辛迪的脖子上绕了四圈，然后将其锁在一根木质支撑梁上。接着，他强奸了她，随后在附近的沙发上安顿下来打盹。他用左轮手枪指着辛迪，警告她不要吵醒他，或者原话是：“你会惹我生气的，你不会想看到我生气的样子。”
While her captor slept, Cindy's mind raced. Her eyes darted around the basement, taking in every detail. There was a pool table and foosball table, a television, a clock, a computer, a rack of women's clothing and all of those dead animals. Cindy knew with absolute certainty that they hadn't been her captor's only victims. She thought about grabbing one of the pool cues and hitting him over the head. But what if he died? She'd be trapped down there, still chained to the beam with no way of calling for help. Or worse, she might not hit him hard enough and he would kill her then and there.
趁着绑架者睡觉时，辛迪的大脑飞速运转。她的目光在地下室里四处扫视，将每一个细节都收入眼底。这里有台球桌和手足球台、一台电视机、一个时钟、一台电脑、一排女装以及所有那些死去的动物。辛迪百分之百确定，这些绝对不是她绑架者的唯一受害者。她想过随手抓起一根台球杆砸他的头。但如果他死了呢？她就会被困在下面，依然被锁在柱子上，无法呼救。或者更糟糕的是，她可能没能狠狠地击中他，而他就会当场杀死她。
Instead, Cindy waited in silence until the man stirred awake. He unchained her, but kept the handcuffs secured around her wrists. Under the static, lifeless stairs of the animals perched around them, he bragged of his world record hunting success and showed off one of his trophies. Then he raped Cindy again on the bare skin rug. Afterwards, his conversation took an even more sinister turn. The man explained how he had brought seven other women to his house, all of whom he kept captive for a week. In an attempt to appeal to his humanity, Cindy tearfully begged to be released so she could see her mother again.
相反，辛迪静静地等待着，直到那名男子醒来。他解开了她的链条，但让手铐依然锁在她的手腕上。在死寂的楼梯下和周围栖息的动物标本注视下，他吹嘘自己世界纪录般的狩猎战绩，并展示了其中一个战利品。接着，他在光秃秃的熊皮地毯上再次强奸了辛迪。事后，他的谈话内容变得更加险恶。这名男子解释说，他曾把另外七名女性带到他家，并将她们每人软禁了一个星期。为了唤醒他的仁慈，辛迪泪流满面地哀求他放她走，好让她能再见到母亲。
Everything's gonna be okay, he reassured her. I'm not going to hurt you. He said that he'd only brought Cindy to his home because he wanted to get his money's worth. But now he liked her so much that he wanted to take her to a remote cabin he owned where they could, quote, make love one more time before he let her go. He owned a plane that he kept at Merrill Field Airport so they could fly out from there. Cindy nodded along, pretending to be fine with his plan. Yet, she knew the only way she was going to survive was if she found a way to escape.
一切都会好的，他安慰她。我不会伤害你的。他说，他把辛迪带回家只是因为想物有所值。但现在他太喜欢她了，想带她去他名下的一间偏远小屋，在那里他们可以——原话是——“再做爱一次”，然后他就放她走。他有一架飞机，停放在梅里尔菲尔德机场，这样他们就可以从那里飞走。辛迪连连点头，假装同意他的计划。然而，她心里清楚，自己能够生还的唯一方法就是找到逃跑的办法。
The sun hadn't yet risen when Cindy was led from the weatherboard house and back into the Buick. She was forced to lie down along the back seat where she was covered with an army blanket. As her captor drove, Cindy remembered that Merrill Field was right by the motel where she was staying with her boyfriend. If she managed to get away somehow, she wouldn't have to run far for help. They arrived at the airport shortly before 5am. Private bush planes lined the acres of quiet, dark field. Cindy's captor pulled up near a blue and white two-seater Super Cub. He got out and began loading the aircraft with things from the trunk of his car.
太阳还没升起，辛迪就被带出木瓦房，重新塞回别克车里。她被迫躺在后座上，身上盖着一条军毯。在绑架者开车时，辛迪记起梅里尔菲尔德机场就在她和男友住的汽车旅馆旁边。如果她能设法逃脱，她就不需要跑很远去求救。他们在凌晨5点前不久抵达机场。私人的丛林飞机排列在数英亩安静黑暗的停机坪上。辛迪的绑架者把车停在一架蓝白相间的双座超级卡布飞机（Super Cub）旁。他下了车，开始把汽车后备箱里的东西往飞机上搬。
Watching from the Buick as he walked back and forth, Cindy suddenly noticed that he'd left the driver's side door ajar. Overcome with nervous energy, she delicately removed her high-heeled shoes, put them aside, and waited. Once the man was over by his plane, Cindy clambered into the front seat and leapt out the open door. Racing barefoot over the gravel runway, Cindy heard the man shout behind her, Stop you bitch or I'll kill you. It took a moment for truck driver Robert Young to register the strange sight before him. A young woman had bolted onto East Fifth Avenue, waving her handcuffed hands in the air and screaming for help. As she sprinted towards Robert's truck, he leaned over to open the passenger side door.
辛迪坐在别克车里看着他来回走动，突然发现他把驾驶员侧的车门留了一条缝。她被紧张的精力所驱使，小心翼翼地脱下高跟鞋，放到一边，然后静静等待。一旦那名男子走到他的飞机旁，辛迪就爬到前座，从开着的门跳了出去。辛迪赤脚在砂石跑道上狂奔，听到身后那名男子大喊：“站住，你这贱人，否则我杀了你。”货车司机罗伯特·杨（Robert Young）花了一会儿才反应过来眼前这诡异的一幕。一名年轻女子冲上了东第五大街，在空中挥舞着戴着手铐的双手，尖叫着寻求帮助。当她向罗伯特的货车冲去时，他探身打开了副驾驶座的车门。
Launching herself inside, the woman yelled, He's going to kill me, get me out of here. According to the book Fair Game, Robert scanned the airfield where the woman had come from but couldn't see who she was referring to. His distressed passenger begged him to hurry, so Robert drove onwards. She asked to be taken to a nearby motel and Robert obliged, pulling over at the mash-in, a low-budget motel 450 feet from Merrill Field. The woman rushed inside. Bewildered, Robert continued driving to work. As soon as he got there, he called the Anchorage Police Department. Ten-year police veteran Greg Baker was halfway through his shift when he got the call to attend the mash-in. By the time he arrived, the handcuffed woman had left in a taxi.
那名女子钻进车里，大喊道：“他要杀了我，带我离开这里。”根据《公平游戏》（Fair Game）一书的记载，罗伯特扫视了女子跑过来的机场，但没有看到她指的是谁。他惊恐的乘客恳求他快点，于是罗伯特继续开车。她要求去附近的汽车旅馆，罗伯特照办了，将车停在距离梅里尔菲尔德机场450英尺的一家名为 Mash-in 的低成本汽车旅馆外。那名女子冲了进去。罗伯特感到困惑，继续开车去上班。一到公司，他就给安克雷奇警察局打了电话。有着十年从警经验的警察格雷格·贝克（Greg Baker）当班正值中途，接到了前往 Mash-in 汽车旅馆的出警电话。等他赶到时，那名戴着手铐的女子已经坐出租车离开了。
She was traced to another motel down the road named The Big Timber. When Officer Baker got there, a front desk clerk directed him to Room 110. He knocked on the door and a young woman answered. She was barefoot and her wrists were red and raw from the handcuffs still clasped around them. Her name was Cindy Paulson. After hearing of her ordeal, Officer Baker escorted Cindy to hospital to undergo an examination. As they drove by Merrill Field, she insisted on showing him her assailant's aircraft. She singled out a blue and white Super Cub, which bore a registration number on its tail, written as small as regulations allowed.
警方顺藤摸瓜，追踪到马路对面另一家名为“大森林”（The Big Timber）的汽车旅馆。当贝克警官赶到那里时，前台接待员把他指引到了110房间。他敲了敲门，一名年轻女子应门。她赤着脚，手腕由于被紧紧铐着而红肿破皮。她的名字叫辛迪·保尔森。在听取了她的悲惨遭遇后，贝克警官护送辛迪前往医院接受检查。当他们开车经过梅里尔菲尔德机场时，她坚持要向他展示她袭击者的飞机。她认出了一架蓝白相间的超级卡布飞机，其机尾上印有一个注册号，字体小到了法规允许的极限。
Upon cross-checking the plane's registration, police discovered it belonged to a man who lived at the Old Harbor Avenue address where Cindy said she had been held captive. Police rushed to the blue-gray weatherboard house only to discover that no one was home. They stood guard over the property and waited. Shortly before 7am, a green Buick sentry pulled into the driveway. Officers descended on the vehicle and its driver, 44-year-old Robert Hanson. Originally from Iowa, Hanson had moved to Alaska with his wife in 1963. The couple settled in Anchorage where they had two children. Hanson had followed in his father's footsteps by becoming a baker and owned the business Hanson's Bakery a few blocks from downtown.
通过交叉核对飞机的注册信息，警方发现它属于一名男子，该男子居住在辛迪所说的她被囚禁的旧港大道地址。警方冲进那栋蓝灰色的木瓦房，却发现空无一人。他们在房产周围把守并等待着。清晨7点前不久，一辆绿色的别克世纪轿车驶入车道。警员们包围了这辆车及其司机——44岁的罗伯特·汉森（Robert Hanson）。汉森原籍艾奥瓦州，于1963年随妻子移居阿拉斯加。这对夫妇在安克雷奇定居并育有两名子女。汉森子承父业成为了一名面包师，并在距离市中心几个街区的地方拥有一家名为“汉森面包店”的生意。
Anchorage police were very familiar with Robert Hanson, known locally as Bob. His bakery wasn't far from the station, so they visited often for coffee and donuts. Hanson was, by all accounts, a stable and religious family man. During his youth, he had been enlisted in the US military and he'd since become an active member of the community. Hanson was unarmed when police surrounded his vehicle. Calmly, he asked them, What can I do for you officers? Cindy Paulson had accurately detailed his appearance and even knew of his stutter.
安克雷奇警方对罗伯特·汉森非常熟悉，当地人称他为鲍勃。他的面包店离警察局不远，所以他们经常去那里喝咖啡吃甜甜圈。根据所有人的说法，汉森是一个稳定且有宗教信仰的顾家好男人。年轻时，他曾应征加入美军，此后一直积极参与社区活动。警方包围他的车辆时，汉森身上没有武器。他平静地问他们：“警官，我能为你们做点什么吗？”辛迪·保尔森准确地描述了他的外貌，甚至知道他口吃。
A bright green baseball cap and green coat were spotted in his car, matching what Cindy said he was wearing when he picked her up. Her descriptions of his house, inside and out, were also spot on. Hanson signed a waiver allowing police to search his car, home and aircraft. There was nothing of evidentiary value in his buick. Cindy's shoes, which she had left behind as evidence of her presence, were not in the vehicle. There was nothing to prove she'd been held captive in Hanson's house, either. The basement full of hunting paraphernalia was just as Cindy described, but there was no wooden beam like the one she'd said she was chained to overnight, nor was there even a chain.
在他的车里发现了一顶亮绿色的棒球帽和一件绿色外套，这与辛迪所说他接她时穿的衣服相符。她对他的房子内外结构的描述也分毫不差。汉森签署了一份豁免书，允许警方搜查他的汽车、住宅和飞机。他的别克车里没有发现具有证据价值的物品。辛迪作为她存在证据而遗留的鞋子并不在车内。也没有任何证据证明她曾被关押在汉森的家里。摆满狩猎用品的地下室正如辛迪所描述的那样，但并没有她所说自己被链子锁过夜的那根木梁，甚至连链子也没有。
Also missing were a yellow towel and washcloth Cindy claimed to have used. A search of Hanson's Super Cub was equally anticlimactic. Hanson was an award-winning trophy hunter who owned an array of pistols, rifles and shotguns, but none matched the wood-handled revolver used against Cindy. Hanson agreed to be interviewed and was polite and cooperative throughout. He denied abducting or raping Cindy Paulson and had an alibi to prove it. Half an hour before Cindy was abducted, Hanson went to the home of a friend named John Henning. He remained there all night, staying up with John until 5.30am drinking beer and planning a fishing trip.
同样不见踪影的还有辛迪声称自己用过的黄色毛巾和洗脸巾。对汉森的超级卡布飞机的搜查同样波澜不惊。汉森是一位屡获殊荣的战利品猎人，拥有一系列手枪、步枪和猎枪，但没有一把符合对辛迪使用的那支木柄左轮手枪。汉森同意接受讯问，并在整个过程中表现得礼貌且配合。他否认绑架或强奸了辛迪·保尔森，并有不在场证明来证明这一点。在辛迪被绑架前半小时，汉森去了名叫约翰·亨宁（John Henning）的朋友家。他在那里待了一整晚，和约翰一直熬夜到凌晨5:30，一边喝啤酒一边计划一次垂钓之旅。
Afterwards, they headed to Merrill Field to install a seat in Hanson's Super Cub. John Henning confirmed Hanson's assertions. A physical examination of Cindy Paulson revealed evidence of vaginal penetration along with the presence of semen. But the examining doctor told investigators that Cindy only had abrasions around her wrists, not her neck, where she said a chain had been looped. Despite this, Cindy maintained her version of events. With Hanson's whereabouts fully accounted for, investigators presumed that Cindy was lying in some capacity. It was clear from her accurate description of both Robert Hanson and his property that Cindy knew him in some way,
之后，他们前往梅里尔菲尔德机场，为汉森的超级卡布飞机安装一个座位。约翰·亨宁证实了汉森的说法。对辛迪·保尔森的身体检查显示有阴道穿透的迹象以及精液的存在。但负责检查的医生告诉调查人员，辛迪的手腕周围有擦伤，但脖子上却没有——她曾说链条曾套在脖子上。尽管如此，辛迪仍然坚持自己的说法。由于汉森的行踪有完整的解释，调查人员推测辛迪在某些方面撒了谎。从她对罗伯特·汉森及其住所的准确描述中，很明显辛迪在某种程度上认识他，
likely through her sex work. But whatever had happened to her the previous night, it couldn't have been at his hands. She likely did meet with a client, though the ordeal she described didn't add up. While Hanson was cagey about any history he might have had with Cindy Paulson, she was adamant that they had met once before. Cindy mentioned that Hanson had propositioned her previously from his Buick. As detailed in the book Fair Game, he had introduced himself using a different name. The two arranged to meet the night before her abduction, but he was a no-show.
很可能是通过她的性工作。但不管前一天晚上她遭遇了什么，绝不可能是出自他之手。她很可能确实见过一个客户，尽管她描述的遭遇说不通。虽然汉森对她与辛迪·保尔森可能存在的任何过往讳莫如深，但她坚称他们以前见过一次面。辛迪提到汉森以前曾用他的别克车向她搭讪。正如《公平游戏》一书中所详述的那样，他曾用一个假名进行自我介绍。两人约定在她被绑架的前一天晚上见面，但他放了鸽子。
This prompted police to wonder whether Cindy harboured resentment towards Hanson for standing her up and costing her income. Was she implicating him in a crime for revenge? Spectacle investigators believed that this was a classic case of a sex worker getting into a disagreement with a client over money. What police described as, quote, a trick gone awry. Cindy was asked to sit a polygraph test. She skipped town with her boyfriend the very next day, never taking the test or informing police of her decision. She confirmed to their suspicions that her version of events were heavily fabricated. By late June, the case was officially closed.
这让警方怀疑辛迪是否对汉森怀恨在心，因为他爽约害她损失了收入。她是为了报复而诬陷他吗？奇观调查人员（Spectacle investigators）认为，这是一个性工作者因金钱问题与客户发生争执的经典案例。警方将其形容为——原话是——“一笔搞砸了的嫖娼交易”。警方要求辛迪接受测谎仪测试。就在第二天，她和男友逃离了该镇，既没有参加测试，也没有将她的决定通知警方。她的行为证实了他们的怀疑，即她的事件版本是被严重虚构的。到六月下旬，该案正式结案。
A note on its file stipulated that no further action was required. Despite this, Greg Baker of Anchorage PD's sexual assault unit never wavered in his belief that Cindy Paulson had been telling the truth about Robert Hanson. Having heard her story firsthand and witnessed her obvious distress, his instincts told him she was genuine. While his colleagues were quick to dismiss Cindy's assertions based on a few uncertain details, there were overlooked or disregarded clues that hinted at Hanson's guilt. At the time of the attack, Hanson's wife and children were vacationing overseas, which gave him full reign of the house. His alibi had come from one of his longtime hunting and fishing friends, not exactly an unbiased and trustworthy third party. And while most people who faced such serious accusations were outraged or indignant, Hanson softly and confidently rebutted the crimes leveled against him.
案卷上的一条备注规定无需采取进一步行动。尽管如此，安克雷奇警察局性侵犯部门的格雷格·贝克坚信辛迪·保尔森关于罗伯特·汉森的说法是实话，从未动摇。在听取了她的一手陈述并目睹了她明显的痛苦后，他的直觉告诉他她是真实的。虽然他的同事们急于根据一些不确定的细节驳回辛迪的主张，但仍有一些被忽视或无视的线索暗示了汉森的罪行。袭击发生时，汉森的妻子和孩子正在海外度假，这让他对房子拥有完全的掌控权。他的不在场证明来自他的一位长期狩猎和钓鱼的朋友，算不上是一个公正且值得信赖的第三方。而且，虽然大多数面对如此严重指控的人都会感到愤怒或激愤，但汉森却温和而自信地反驳了针对他的罪行。
Then there was a statement given by a Merrill Field security guard on duty the morning Cindy said she was taken there. He had seen a green Buick sentry arriving at around 5am and watched it move to a corner of the airfield. This correlated with Cindy's story. Shortly thereafter, a man wearing a green coat and bright green baseball cap ran out from behind a blue and white Super Cub plane. Upon noticing the security guard observing him, the man slowed to a walk, returned to the Buick, got in and sped off along East 5th Avenue. Sensing Robert Hanson was his guy, Officer Baker trawled through police records to see what he could uncover. To his surprise, Hanson's file was extensive. He'd spent short stints in prison throughout his life for a range of offences. In 1960, Hanson, who was then around 20 years old, received his first conviction. He pleaded guilty to arson after setting fire to a bus garage belonging to his former high school. Due to Hanson's stutter and severe acne, his high school experience had been marred with bullying, taunts and rejection.
然后是一份由梅里尔菲尔德机场保安提供的证词，他在辛迪被带到那里的那天早晨值班。他看到一辆绿色的别克世纪轿车大约在凌晨5点抵达，并看着它开到机场的一个角落。这与辛迪的故事相吻合。此后不久，一名穿着绿色外套和亮绿色棒球帽的男子从一架蓝白相间的超级卡布飞机后面跑出来。一察觉到保安在观察他，这名男子便放慢脚步变成步行，回到别克车里，上车后沿东第五大街疾驰而去。贝克警官直觉罗伯特·汉森就是作案人，于是查阅了警方档案，看看能发现什么。令他惊讶的是，汉森的档案堆积如山。他一生中曾因各种罪行多次在监狱里度过短暂时光。1960年，当时大约20岁的汉森迎来了他的第一次定罪。他承认纵火罪，因为他点燃了他前高中所有的一个公交车库。由于汉森结巴且患有严重的青春痘，他的高中生活伴随着霸凌、嘲讽和排挤。
This had fueled his desire to seek revenge against the institution. I guess I burned down the bus barn because I hated the school with the divine passion. I would do whatever I could think of to get back at that monster school that did Bob Hanson a personal wrong. Hanson was sentenced to three years at a state reformatory where he was diagnosed with an infantile and antisocial personality. This was deemed to be the result of a strict upbringing and low self-esteem, inflamed by the torment of his peers. While incarcerated, he spoke of having vengeful and destructive fantasies, some of which featured girls who'd rejected his advances or made fun of him. Quote, It's hard to explain what it's like to always be wanting to see others go out on dates. I was just seeing everybody else get theirs. Hanson soon realized that speaking honestly about his mental demons only hindered his parole efforts, so he started to play the system by portraying himself as rehabilitated and harmless. Although he was unable to fully suppress his infantile personality, Hanson could hide his antisocial attitudes.
这助长了他对该机构进行报复的渴望。我猜我烧了公交车库是因为我对这所学校有着神圣的愤怒。我会尽我所能去报复那个对鲍勃·汉森犯下个人错误的怪物学校。汉森被判处在州少管所服刑三年，在那里他被诊断出患有幼稚型和反社会人格。这被认为是严格的家教和低自尊的结果，并被同龄人的折磨进一步激化。在服刑期间，他谈到自己有复仇和破坏性的幻想，其中一些以拒绝他的追求或取笑他的女孩为主角。原话是：“很难解释那种总是渴望看到别人出去约会的感觉是什么样的。我只是看着别人都得到了他们想得到的。”汉森很快意识到，诚实地谈论他的精神恶魔只会阻碍他的假释努力，于是他开始玩弄体制，将自己描绘成一个已经改过自新且无害的人。尽管他无法完全压抑自己的幼稚人格，但汉森能够隐藏他的反社会态度。
Doing so, coupled with his record of good conduct, led to his parole in 1963. Yet, Robert Hanson never managed to stay out of trouble for long. After stealing a chainsaw from a shop, he was diagnosed with bipolar-effective disorder. The courts ruled he needed an ongoing routine of medication and therapy to overcome his behavioral problems, but Hanson received neither. It was a series of crimes Hanson committed in late 1971 that really drew Officer Greg Baker's attention. The first was the attempted abduction of a woman from her Anchorage apartment. Hanson had made eye contact with her at a set of traffic lights and followed her home to ask her out. She rejected him, and a week later, he confronted her at gunpoint with the intention of taking her elsewhere.
这样做，再加上他良好的行为记录，使他在1963年获得了假释。然而，罗伯特·汉森从未能在很长一段时间内保持遵纪守法。在从商店偷了一把链锯后，他被诊断患有双相情感障碍。法院裁定他需要进行长期的药物治疗和心理治疗来克服行为问题，但汉森两者都没做。正是汉森在1971年底犯下的一系列罪行真正引起了格雷格·贝克警官的注意。第一起是一位女性在安克雷奇的公寓险遭绑架。汉森在红绿灯处与她有过眼神接触，并尾随她回家向她表白。她拒绝了他，一周后，他持枪与她对峙，意图将她带往别处。
His plan was interrupted by the police, and Hanson was charged with assault with a deadly weapon. He was released on bail, during which time he successfully abducted a second woman from outside an Anchorage coffee shop. She was driven outside the city by the gun wielding Hanson, who kept her bound as he repeatedly assaulted and raped her. At one point, he spoke of taking her to a remote cabin, though he was unable to reach it due to snow on the road. The charges against him in relation to this case were ultimately dropped, but the similarities between this incident and what later happened to Cindy Paulson were cleared. There were many other instances in which Hanson had threatened or harmed women, though nothing came of these reports. Most of his misbehaviour centred around the Tenderloin district and involved dancers or sex workers. Some of his survivors opted not to go to police in fear of retribution from Hanson. Others were brushed aside by a system mired in victim blaming and discrimination.
他的计划被警方打断，汉森被指控犯有持致命武器袭击罪。他获得保释，在此期间，他成功地从安克雷奇一家咖啡店外绑架了第二名女性。她被持枪的汉森带到城外，汉森一路捆绑着她，并对她进行了反复的虐待和强奸。在某个时候，他曾谈到要带她去一个偏远的小屋，尽管由于路面积雪，他未能到达。与此案相关的对他的指控最终被撤销，但这次事件与后来发生在辛迪·保尔森身上的事情之间的相似之处昭然若揭。还有许多其他汉森威胁或伤害女性的实例，尽管这些报告最终都不了了之。他的大部分不良行为都集中在红灯区，涉及舞者或性工作者。他的一些幸存者选择不报警，是害怕遭到汉森的报复。其他人则被深陷受害者责备和歧视的体制所无视。
One night, police were called to the Great Alaskan Bush Company, one of Hanson's many regular horns. Upon arrival, officers found Hanson and a dancer, Judy Russell, arguing out the front. According to reports, Judy had jumped off stage mid-performance and began clawing and kicking at Hanson. She told attending officers that Hanson had recently abducted her at gunpoint. At that time, Judy worked at a club called Embers, and Hanson had propositioned her for sex in exchange for money. What followed was a harrowing ordeal, during which Hanson bound Judy in his camper pickup and attempted to drive her out of the city. Judy was able to escape, but at the time, she couldn't recall any key identifying details about her abductor. Following this frightening ordeal, Judy left Embers and started dancing at the Great Alaskan Bush Company.
一天晚上，警方接到报警，前往大阿拉斯加丛林公司（Great Alaskan Bush Company），这是汉森经常光顾的众多风月场所之一。到达现场后，警官们发现汉森和一名舞者朱迪·罗素（Judy Russell）正在门前争吵。根据报告，朱迪在表演中途跳下舞台，开始抓挠和踢打汉森。她告诉出警的警官，汉森最近曾持枪绑架过她。当时，朱迪在一家名为“余烬”（Embers）的俱乐部工作，汉森曾向她搭讪，提出用金钱换取性服务。随之而来的是一段悲惨的经历，期间汉森将朱迪绑在他的露营小货车里，试图开车将她带出城。朱迪设法逃脱了，但在当时，她记不清关于绑架者的任何关键识别细节。在这段可怕的经历之后，朱迪离开了“余烬”俱乐部，开始在大阿拉斯加丛林公司跳舞。
When Robert Hanson happened to show up there, she immediately recognized his pockmarked, bespectacled face and launched herself at him in anger. Hanson didn't deny knowing Judy, but disputed her version of events. He agreed that he had offered her money in exchange for sex acts, but denied abducting her. Quote, She got mad when I wouldn't play ball when she tried to jack up the price. Hanson had made a similar excuse when a dancer from the Kit Kat Club accused him of abducting and raping her at gunpoint. It was clear that he held dancers and sex workers in poor regard. He once quipped to police, quote, You can't rape a prostitute, can you? Despite multiple women having made near identical allegations against Hanson over a 12-year period, they were ignored.
当罗伯特·汉森碰巧出现在那里时，她立刻认出了他那张满是麻坑、戴着眼镜的脸，并愤怒地扑向他。汉森并不否认认识朱迪，但对她的叙述版本提出了异议。他承认他曾向她提供金钱以换取性行为，但否认绑架她。原话是：“当我拒绝在她试图抬高价格时同流合污时，她生气了。”当猫咪俱乐部（Kit Kat Club）的一名舞者指控汉森持枪绑架并强奸她时，汉森也作出了类似借口。很显然，他极其轻视舞者和性工作者。他曾对警方调侃道，原话是：“你不能强奸一个妓女，对吧？”尽管有多名女性在长达12年的时间里对汉森做出近乎完全相同的指控，但它们都被无视了。
Police trusted Hanson, who had molded himself into an upstanding citizen, albeit with a penchant for visiting strip clubs and hiring sex workers. Hanson didn't deny he was unfaithful to his wife, but he didn't want his family to find out. The police obliged by not pursuing the incident with Judy Russell any further. By the time Robert Hanson was on Officer Greg Baker's radar, he was a master manipulator who knew how to influence police. He made note of what led to his incarceration in the past and now fully understood the importance of a good reputation, the appearance of mental stability, procuring alibis, and targeting victims who were unreliable in the eyes of authority. He fostered a successful business and home life, presenting himself as a well-respected, community-focused everyman, the last person anyone would suspect of doing harm. But as far as Officer Baker was concerned, Hanson wasn't just a serial sex offender.
警方信任汉森，他把自己塑造为一个正派的公民，尽管有着光顾脱衣舞俱乐部和雇佣性工作者的癖好。汉森不否认他对妻子不忠，但他不想让家人发现。警方通过不再对朱迪·罗素的事件进行进一步追查來予以配合。当罗伯特·汉森进入格雷格·贝克警官的视线时，他已经是一个操控大师，深谙如何影响警方。他记下了过去导致自己入狱的原因，现在完全理解了良好声誉、精神稳定表象、寻找不在场证明以及将目标锁定在当局眼中不可靠的受害者身上的重要性。他培育了成功的生意和家庭生活，将自己呈现为一个广受尊敬、以社区为中心的平凡人，是任何人怎么也不会怀疑会作恶的最后一个人。但在贝克警官看来，汉森不仅仅是一个连环性罪犯。
During the Cindy Paulson investigation, Hanson's Buick had been searched. 223 ammunition was located under the driver's seat and rolled up elastic bandages were spotted on the dashboard. Baker was aware of the murder of Sherry Morrow, whose bullet-riddled remains were found the previous year, partially buried in a sandbar spanning the Canick River. Sherry had been blindfolded with an elastic bandage, then shot with a 223-caliber bullet, as was Paula Goulding, who was also found in a shallow grave by the Canick River. Given Hanson's keen interest in hunting and his award-winning skill, Baker was certain he was the serial killer who had been killing women in the wilderness surrounding Anchorage. It appeared as though Hanson was carrying out his own fantasy version of the most dangerous game. The phrase came from a short story by Richard Connell, in which a big game hunter grows bored with the pastime and decides to hunt humans instead. The fictional character would release his captives into the wilderness, pursue them, then gun them down.
在对辛迪·保尔森案的调查中，汉森的别克车曾遭到搜查。驾驶座下方发现了 .223 口径弹药，仪表盘上还看到了卷起来的弹性绷带。贝克了解雪莉·莫罗（Sherry Morrow）谋杀案，她的尸体千疮百孔，于前一年被发现，部分埋在横跨卡尼克河（Canick River）的一个沙洲中。雪莉被一条弹性绷带蒙住双眼，然后被一颗 .223 口径的子弹射杀，保拉·古尔丁（Paula Goulding）也是如此，她同样被发现在卡尼克河畔的一个浅坑中。鉴于汉森对狩猎的热情以及他屡获殊荣的技能，贝克确信他就是一直在安克雷奇周边荒野中杀害女性的连环杀手。汉森似乎正在将理查德·康奈尔（Richard Connell）的一篇短篇小说中的最危险游戏变成他自己的幻想版本。这个短语来自理查德·康奈尔的一篇短篇小说，其中一个大猎物猎人对消遣感到厌倦，转而决定捕猎人类。小说中的角色会将他的俘虏释放到荒野中，追捕他们，然后将他们枪杀。
Robert Hanson's criminal history showed an escalation in violence, and Officer Baker saw how this trajectory could result in murder. He put together a report on everything he had discovered about Robert Hanson and delivered it to the Alaska State Troopers headquarters, where it wound up in the hands of Sergeant Glenn Flovey. The Sergeant was able to track down Cindy Paulson for an interview. She told him she was certain that Robert Hanson had been her abductor, and was certain she would have been murdered had she not escaped at Merrill Field Airport. Sergeant Flovey, like Greg Baker before him, firmly believed Cindy, and the suspect profile of the serial killer prowling Anchorage that had been provided by the FBI's Behavioral Sciences Unit matched Hanson to a T. On October 27, 1983, two plainclothes police sergeants arrived at a squat single-story building on the corner of East 9th Avenue and Ingra Street in Anchorage. Merrill Field was just a few minutes drive east, while the Tenderloin District was a short distance west. It was approaching 8.30 am when the officers approached a shop front with a sign above it that read, Hanson's Bakery. Nearby, a man in a white Baker's uniform and apron was collecting something from a car.
罗伯特·汉森的犯罪历史显示出暴力倾向的升级，贝克警官看清了这种轨迹如何最终导致谋杀。他将自己关于罗伯特·汉森所发现的一切写成了一份报告，并将其提交给阿拉斯加州骑警总部，最终落入了格伦·弗洛维（Glenn Flovey）警长手中。警长成功找到了辛迪·保尔森进行采访。她告诉他，她确信罗伯特·汉森就是她的绑架者，并确信如果不是自己在梅里尔菲尔德机场逃脱，她就已经被谋杀了。弗洛维警长和之前的格雷格·贝克一样，坚信辛迪的话，而且联邦调查局（FBI）行为科学部提供的在安克雷奇四处游荡的连环杀手的嫌疑人画像与汉森完全吻合。1983年10月27日，两名便衣警长抵达安克雷奇东第九大街与英格街交界处的一栋单层低矮建筑。梅里尔菲尔德机场向东驱车仅需几分钟，而红灯区则在西边不远处。临近上午8点30分，警官们走近了一家店面，上面的招牌写着：“汉森面包店”。附近，一名穿着白色面包师制服和围裙的男子正在从车里拿东西。
The officers approached him and asked, Robert Hanson, Hanson turned to face them. They asked if he would be willing to talk with them about some cases under investigation. Sure, Hanson replied. As detailed in the book Butcher Baker, Glenn Flovey had gone to a lot of effort to set up the interview room just so. Crime scene photos and pictures of the victims were arranged on a desk alongside stacks of manila folders. Some of the files were labelled with names of Hanson's hunting associates.
警官们走近他并问道：“罗伯特·汉森？”汉森转身面对他们。他们问他是否愿意与他们谈谈一些正在调查的案件。“当然，”汉森回答道。正如《屠夫面包师》（Butcher Baker）一书中所详述的那样，格伦·弗洛维费了很大力气把审讯室布置得恰到好处。案发现场照片和受害者图片与一叠牛皮纸文件夹一起摆放在一张桌子上。其中一些文件夹上贴着汉森狩猎伙伴名字的标签。
A large map of the Canick River Valley was pinned to a wall. Two X marks had been drawn inside a large circle. Scrawled in all capital letters next to this were the words, Hanson identified in this area. After being escorted into the room, Hanson was left there alone for a little while so he could take it all in. Soon, Glenn Flovey strode into the room and began his interrogation. Although Hanson admitted to having a criminal record, he insisted that was all in the past. Questioning dragged on for hours covering every aspect of Hanson's history,
一张巨大的卡尼克河谷地图被钉在墙上。在一个大圆圈内画了两个X。旁边用全大写字母潦草地写着这样几个字：“在此区域内识别出汉森”。在被护送进房间后，汉森独自留在那里一会儿，以便他能将这一切尽收眼底。不久，格伦·弗洛维大步走进房间，开始了审讯。尽管汉森承认自己有犯罪前科，但他坚称那都已经是过去式了。审讯持续了数小时，涵盖了汉森历史的方方面面，
from his initial charges of arson and theft to the allegations of abduction and rape. Interviewing officers stopped short of mentioning the murders for now. They discussed Hanson's first known offence against a woman, the botched abduction of an anchorage teenager from her apartment in 1971. When apprehended for this crime, Hanson claimed he had blacked out and therefore had no recollection of the event. As he sat before Sergeant Flovey in an interrogation room adorned with the faces of missing or murdered women, Hanson admitted that he had never really suffered any memory blackout in his life. According to the book Fair Game, this admission likely stemmed from Hanson knowing he wouldn't face any consequences
从他最初的纵火和盗窃指控到绑架和强奸的指控。审讯警官目前暂且没有提及谋杀案。他们讨论了汉森针对女性的第一起已知罪行——1971年从安克雷奇一处公寓未遂绑架一名十几岁女孩的案件。当因这起罪行被捕时，汉森声称自己当时失去了意识，因此对该事件毫无记忆。当他坐在审讯室里面对弗洛维警长时，周围装饰着失踪或被谋杀女性的面孔，汉森承认他一生中从未真正经历过任何记忆黑洞。根据《公平游戏》一书的记载，这种供认很可能源于汉森知道十多年后揭露真相也不会面临任何后果，
for revealing the truth more than a decade later. But it did expose him as a liar. Soon, the line of questioning turned to Sherry Morrow. When shown a photograph of the murdered 23-year-old, Hanson asked, Who's that? He refused to admit any knowledge of her murder or Paula Gouldings. He did say that he occasionally visited the areas where their bodies were found before adding, I didn't shoot anybody. I would not hurt anybody.
但这确实暴露了他是一个骗子的事实。很快，盘问的焦点转向了雪莉·莫罗。当被展示一张被害23岁女孩的照片时，汉森问：“那是谁？”他拒绝承认自己对她或保拉·古尔丁的谋杀有任何了解。他确实说过，他偶尔会去发现他们尸体的地方，然后又补充道：“我没有枪杀任何人。我不会伤害任何人。”
Meanwhile, police swarmed Robert Hanson's home and workplace to execute a search warrant. Word of their presence quickly spread to the disbelief of his family and friends. They had yet to learn why authorities had honed in on the seemingly stable and neighbourly Hanson and couldn't comprehend the idea that he might be in trouble with the law. The police activity soon peaked the interest of Joan, the wife of Hanson's close friend, John Henning. She wondered whether their efforts related to something her husband had told her several months earlier. Shortly after a panicked Cindy Paulson had run handcuffed and barefoot from Merrill Field Airport, Robert Hanson made a phone call.
与此同时，警方蜂拥至罗伯特·汉森的家和工作场所执行搜查令。他们出现的消息迅速传开，令他的家人和朋友感到难以置信。他们还没弄明白为什么当局会把目标锁定在看似稳重且有邻家风范的汉森身上，无法理解他会惹上官司的想法。警方的行动很快激起了汉森挚友约翰·亨宁的妻子琼（Joan）的兴趣。她想知道他们的行动是否与她丈夫几个月前告诉她的事情有关。就在惊恐的辛迪·保尔森戴着手铐赤脚从梅里尔菲尔德机场逃跑后不久，罗伯特·汉森打了一通电话。
It was around 5.30am when John Henning picked up the receiver to hear Hanson, his longtime friend, on the other line. Hanson asked if they could meet at his bakery right away. John was confused but agreed. When John arrived, Hanson told him how his wife and children were overseas and in an effort to overcome loneliness, he had picked up a sex worker. He took her back to his house where they had sex before she raised the price of her services. Hanson wouldn't pay and now she was seeking revenge by falsely accusing him of rape.
大约凌晨5点30分，约翰·亨宁拿起话筒，听到他的老朋友汉森在电话那头。汉森问他们是否可以马上在面包店见面。约翰感到困惑但还是同意了。约翰到达后，汉森告诉他，由于妻子和孩子在海外，为了克服孤独，他接了一名性工作者。他把她带回自己家，两人发生性关系后，她提高了性服务的价格。汉森不肯付钱，现在她通过虚假指控他强奸来进行报复。
Hanson started as he spoke. He was clearly very anxious. Fearing he might be arrested, he told John he didn't want his family to find out and be hurt by his adultery. He asked if John would give him an alibi for 11.30pm until 5.30am. The timeframe in which Cindy Paulson was abducted held captive and taken to the airfield. John believed Hanson and like many others, he dismissed the incident as a trick gone awry. To help his friend, John confirmed his alibi when police came knocking. As John was a well-respected local businessman, his statement was given considerable credibility. John had told his wife about the favour he'd done for his friend.
汉森说话时有些结巴，显然非常焦虑。唯恐自己被捕，他告诉约翰他不想让家人发现并因他的通奸行为而受到伤害。他请求约翰为他在晚上11点30分到凌晨5点30分之间提供不在场证明。这个时间段正是辛迪·保尔森被绑架、软禁并被带到机场的时间。约翰相信了汉森，和许多其他人一样，他把这起事件轻描淡写地看作是一次搞砸了的嫖娼交易。为了帮助朋友，当警察找上门来时，约翰证实了他的不在场证明。由于约翰是当地备受尊敬的商界人士，他的证词被赋予了相当高的可信度。约翰曾将自己为朋友做的好事告诉了妻子。
As described in the book Butcher Baker, when John heard that Hanson's properties were being searched, she got in her car and cruised past Hanson's residence. Upon seeing the heavy police presence and speaking with officers at the scene, she realised it was time for her husband to come clean. John Henning contacted investigators and admitted that he'd provided a false alibi for Hanson on the night of Cindy Paulson's abduction and rape. Henning thought he'd been looking out for Hanson and his family by covering for him. He had no idea how serious the incident had actually been.
正如《屠夫面包师》一书中所描述的那样，当约翰听到汉森的房产正在被搜查时，她坐上车，从汉森的住宅前驶过。在看到大批警察并与现场警官交谈后，她意识到是时候让丈夫说出真相了。约翰·亨宁联系了调查人员，承认自己在辛迪·保尔森被绑架和强奸的当晚为汉森提供了虚假的不在场证明。亨宁以为他为汉森和他的家人作掩护是在照顾他们。他根本不知道这起事件实际上有多么严重。
Despite now having no alibi for the night Cindy Paulson was attacked, Robert Hanson still denied being involved. It didn't matter. Police had enough evidence now to charge him with Cindy's abduction and rape. He was remanded on a $500,000 bond. Hanson's Old Harbor Avenue property was teeming with state troopers, searching for any evidence to link him to other crimes. The houses' communal rooms were neat and organised.
尽管现在没有了辛迪·保尔森遇袭当晚的不在场证明，罗伯特·汉森仍然否认自己参与其中。这已经无关紧要了。警方现在有足够的证据以辛迪的绑架和强奸罪起诉他。他被还押候审，保释金为50万美元。汉森的旧港大道房产里挤满了州警，他们正在搜寻任何能将他与其他罪行联系起来的证据。房子里的公共房间井然有序、干净整洁。
In the living area, knickknacks were arranged in tidy rows on shelves and had couches framed a small coffee table. Family photos lined the hallway, as did a portrait of Jesus Christ. Searching some cupboards, officers found elastic bandages and a bag full of cash. Shotguns and rifles were recovered from a closet in the living room and a hidden cabinet. Given that Hanson had been previously convicted of a felony, he was forbidden by law to possess any firearms. He would be charged accordingly.
在起居区，小摆设在架子上整齐地排列成行，沙发环绕着一张小茶几。走廊里挂满了家庭照片，还有一幅耶稣基督的画像。搜查了一些橱柜后，警官们发现了弹性绷带和一袋现金。起居室的壁橱和一个隐藏的柜子里搜出了猎枪和步枪。鉴于汉森先前有重罪定罪，法律禁止他拥有任何枪支。他将为此受到相应的指控。
There was also a strange kit that contained tools for creating disguises, including a fake mustache, nail polish and skin adhesive. A number of stolen goods were discovered, indicating Hanson's kleptomania had never gone away. The troopers made their way downstairs to the basement, where Cindy Paulson said she'd been held captive. They made their way around the room, carefully pressing against the wood-panelled walls. One portion suddenly gave way.
还有一个奇怪的工具包，里面包含用于伪装的工具，包括假胡子、指甲油和皮肤粘合剂。还发现了许多赃物，表明汉森的偷窃癖从未消失。州警们来到楼下辛迪·保尔森声称自己被囚禁的地下室。他们在房间四周仔细察看，小心翼翼地按压木质镶板墙壁。其中一部分突然塌陷了。
Behind it was a small, secret room. In its centre was the wooden beam Cindy had described being chained to. After hours of meticulous searching, there was only one area left unexamined, the attic. One trooper offered to climb up into the small, cramped space. Crawling across the beams, he found a stack of animal hides. Continuing onwards, he felt with his hands for anything that might be hidden there. As he pressed into some insulation in one corner, it suddenly collapsed. Beneath it lay several firearms, including a .223 calibre Ruger Mini-14 rifle.
后面是一个狭小的秘密房间。房间中央就是辛迪描述过的拴着链条的那根木梁。经过几个小时的细致搜查，只剩下一个区域没有检查过——阁楼。一名州警主动提出爬进这个狭小局促的空间。他沿着横梁爬行，发现了一叠动物皮毛。继续向前，他用双手摸索着可能藏在那里的任何东西。当他按压一个角落的隔热材料时，它突然坍塌了。下方躺着几把火器，其中包括一支 .223 口径的鲁格 Mini-14 步枪。
There was also a little plastic bag that contained a number of women's rings, watches and necklaces. One had an arrowhead pendant. There was another item found in Hansen's house that was particularly noteworthy. While examining the bedroom he shared with his wife, troopers uncovered a piece of paper stashed behind the bedhead. It was an aeronautical chart, a type of map designed to assist pilots in the navigation of aircraft. The map depicted a huge, sprawling overview of Anchorage and its outskirts. There was the Kinnick River valley to the north of the city, the Kenai Peninsula that jutted out below, and the Port City of Seward further south. The map had been marked with many little black asterisks.
还有一个小塑料袋，里面装着许多女性的戒指、手表和项链。其中一个带有箭头吊坠。在汉森家里还发现了另一件特别引人注目的物品。在检查他和妻子共用的卧室时，州警在床头后面藏着的一张纸被揭晓了。那是一张航空图，一种旨在协助飞行员进行飞机导航的地图。地图上描绘了安克雷奇及其市郊庞大而广阔的全景。北部是基尼克河谷（Kinnick River valley），下方突出的是基奈半岛（Kenai Peninsula），更南部则是港口城市苏厄德（Seward）。地图上标有许多黑色的小星号。
Most of them were dotted along the Kinnick River, though there were many others drawn further out. As Glen Flothey studied the map, it suddenly dawned on him. Hansen had scrawled an asterisk on the exact locations where a Clutner Annie, Joanna Messina, Sherry Morrow and Paula Goulding were found. In total, his map featured 21 such markings. Although Hansen was still only charged with abducting and raping Cindy Paulson, the case was already starting to look like the biggest Alaska had ever seen. Investigators had more evidence of the enormity of his crimes, including Hansen's Ruger rifle, which was confirmed to have fired the bullets that killed Sherry Morrow and Paula Goulding. Furthermore, the friends and families of women missing from Anchorage's Tenderloin district had been shown the items of jewelry hidden in Hansen's attic, many of which were recognized as having belonged to their loved ones.
它们大多点缀在基尼克河沿岸，不过还有许多被标记在更远的地方。当格伦·弗洛西研究这张地图时，他突然明白了。汉森在安妮·克鲁特纳、乔安娜·梅西纳、雪莉·莫罗和宝拉·古尔丁被发现的具体地点潦草地画上了星号。他的地图上一共有21个这样的标记。尽管当时汉森仍只被指控绑架和强奸辛迪·保尔森，但这个案子已经开始显露出阿拉斯加有史以来最大案件的迹象。调查人员掌握了他滔天罪行的更多证据，包括汉森的鲁格步枪，经证实，正是这把枪发射了杀死雪莉·莫罗和宝拉·古尔丁的子弹。此外，安克雷奇特德洛因区失踪女性的朋友和家人们被展示了藏在汉森阁楼里的珠宝，其中许多被认出是他们所爱之人的遗物。
The arrowhead pendant was the spitting image of a necklace that Sherry Morrow was known to wear every single day. Business cards that featured the names of some of the missing women were also discovered in Hansen's garage. Prior to Hansen's arrest, a renowned criminal profiler had stated that the person responsible for the murders would be collecting keepsakes from each of his victims, like a trophy hunter hoarding parts of the animal they had killed as a representation of their success and to relive the hunt from memory. With the evidence against Hansen adding up, it was believed he could be compelled to confess. After some negotiating, a deal was struck with his attorney. If Hansen pleaded guilty to the murders of a Clutner Annie, Joanna Messina, Sherry Morrow and Paula Goulding, then his wife and children would be spared the humiliation and pain of a highly publicized trial.
那枚箭头吊坠与雪莉·莫罗每天佩戴的项链一模一样。在汉森的车库里还发现了印有部分失踪女性名字的名片。在汉森被捕之前，一位著名的犯罪侧写师曾表示，谋杀案的幕后黑手会从每个受害者身上收集纪念品，就像奖杯猎人囤积他们杀死的动物身体部位一样，以此作为成功的象征并从记忆中重温狩猎过程。随着对汉森不利的证据不断增加，人们相信他会被迫认罪。经过一番协商，他的律师达成了一项协议。如果汉森对谋杀安妮·克鲁特纳、乔安娜·梅西纳、雪莉·莫罗和宝拉·古尔丁的罪行认罪，那么他的妻子和孩子就可以免受广受关注的审判所带来的羞辱和痛苦。
The case would be wrapped up quickly so as to receive little attention from the media and Hansen could serve out his sentence in a federal penitentiary. On February 22, 1984, Hansen's attorney escorted him to a meeting with the prosecution team so he could provide a full confession. Hansen couldn't provide a Clutner Annie's true identity, but he said she was his first murder victim. He'd picked her up from downtown Anchorage and stabbed her to death north of the city. Joanna Messina from Seward was his second. Hansen killed her upon realizing she was a sex worker who had no genuine interest in him. Posing as a high-paying photographer, Hansen lured Sherry Morrow, the first woman he took out to his Canick River Valley hunting grounds. Upon reaching the sandbar that spanned the river, Hansen brought his car to a stop and pulled Sherry out. She wasn't cooperating, so Hansen retrieved his rifle and sat under a tree waiting for her to settle.
案件将迅速了结，以便少受媒体关注，汉森可以在联邦监狱服刑。1984年2月22日，汉森的律师陪同他与控方团队会面，以便他能够供认不讳。汉森无法提供安妮·克鲁特纳的真实身份，但他说她是他的第一个谋杀受害者。他把她从安克雷奇市中心接走，并在该市北部将她刺死。来自苏厄德的乔安娜·梅西纳是他的第二个受害者。汉森意识到她是一名对他没有真正兴趣的性工作者后杀害了她。汉森伪装成一名高薪摄影师，引诱了雪莉·莫罗，她是他带到卡尼克河谷狩猎场的第一个女人。到达横跨河流的沙洲时，汉森把车停下，把雪莉拉了出去。她很不配合，于是汉森取回步枪，坐在树下等她平静下来。
According to Hansen, Sherry stood over him, kicking and screaming, which prompted him to point the rifle up and shoot her. This claim contradicted evidence from the crime scene which showed Sherry was blindfolded and had been shot three times in the back. After burying Sherry in the silt and sand, Hansen left with her arrowhead necklace as a keepsake. Paula Goulding suffered a similar fate in the valley. Then there was survivor Cindy Paulson, who Hansen finally admitted to abducting and raping. He also admitted to the murder of Andrea Altieri, a dancer who had vanished after meeting a man who was going to take her on a shopping spree. Andrea wore a custom-made necklace that featured a pendant in the shape of a fish, given to her by a friend. It was found among the jewelry stored in Hansen's attic.
据汉森称，雪莉站在他上方，又踢又叫，这促使他举起步枪向她射击。这一说法与犯罪现场的证据相矛盾，现场证据显示雪莉被蒙住双眼，背部中枪三枪。将雪莉埋在淤泥和沙子里后，汉森拿走了她的箭头项链作为纪念品。宝拉·古尔丁在山谷中遭遇了类似的命运。然后是幸存者辛迪·保尔森，汉森最终承认绑架并强奸了她。他还承认谋杀安妮塔·阿尔蒂里，一名在遇见一个要带她去血拼的男子后失踪的舞者。安妮塔戴着一条朋友送的定制项链，项链上有一个鱼形吊坠。它在汉森阁楼存放的珠宝中被发现。
Hansen said he abducted Andrea just two weeks after he killed Sherry Morrow. He had driven Andrea, blindfolded and handcuffed, to the Kinnick Valley area and pulled up to an isolated spot near a railroad bridge. Hansen had brought another woman there a week prior and raped her, but ultimately let her go. Andrea endured a similar experience, though hers ended fatally. Hansen claimed Andrea had reached for his pistol, causing them to scuffle. Hansen pried it from her grasp, and as the fight continued, Andrea put her fingers behind Hansen's glasses and pressed them into his eye sockets. In response, Hansen shot her dad. He filled a duffel bag with gravel and tied it around Andrea's neck, before pushing her body off the railroad bridge into the Kinnick River below.
汉森说他在杀死雪莉·莫罗两周后绑架了安妮塔。他开车把被蒙住眼睛、戴上手铐的安妮塔带到基尼克山谷地区，在铁路桥附近的一个偏僻地点停了下来。汉森一周前曾把另一个女人带到那里并强奸了她，但最终放了她。安妮塔经历了类似的遭遇，尽管她的结局是致命的。汉森声称安妮塔伸手去拿他的手枪，导致两人发生争斗。汉森从她手中挣脱手枪，在争斗继续时，安妮塔将手指伸到汉森的眼镜后面，按进他的眼窝。作为回应，汉森开枪打死了她。他在一个行李袋里装满砾石，绑在安妮塔的脖子上，然后将她的尸体从铁路桥推落到下方的基尼克河中。
After Hansen concluded his detailed confession, District Attorney Victor Krum stood. In a no-nonsense tone, Krum informed Hansen that they knew he hadn't been completely honest with them. Hansen's aviation map indicated he had killed many more women. The forests were covered with winter snow, but as soon as spring arrived and the ice thawed, state troopers would be taking sniffer dogs out to every area marked on the map until they found the rest of Hansen's victims. DA Krum Snapped If you think this is the end, we're gonna prosecute you on every one of these cases. There's gonna be a trial for everything. The ordinarily meek and mild-mannered Hansen turned bright red. He looked furious. In a low voice, Hansen muttered, quote, Dirty fucking whores.
汉森详细供认后，地区检察官维克托·克鲁姆站了起来。克鲁姆用不容商榷的语气告诉汉森，他们知道他并没有对他们完全坦白。汉森的航空地图表明他杀害了更多女性。森林里覆盖着冬雪，但一旦春天到来冰雪融化，州骑警就会带着缉毒犬前往地图上标记的每一个地方，直到找到汉森剩下的受害者。地区检察官克鲁姆厉声说道：“如果你认为这就是结束，我们将在所有这些案件中起诉你。每一件事都要接受审判。”平时温和顺从的汉森脸色通红。他看起来暴怒无比。汉森压低声音咕哝道：“该死的婊子。”
Finally, the prosecutors were getting a real look at the men who had attacked and murdered so many women. Another deal was hastily arranged. If Hansen provided further confessions and assisted state troopers in locating his remaining victims, then he would only be charged with the four murders he'd already admitted to. He Agreed Hansen claimed to have killed 17 women, not the 21 investigators suspected due to his map. His victims were always vulnerable women from the Tenderloin District, whose disappearances would be easily overlooked or disregarded by authorities. This systemic prejudice had ensured that Hansen maintained his killing streak without fear of apprehension. Hansen liked to big note himself to the women he abducted, sometimes telling them he was a doctor or a lawyer.
终于，检察官们得以真正看清这个袭击并谋杀如此多女性的男人的真面目。另一项协议仓促达成。如果汉森提供进一步的供词并协助州警定位他剩余的受害者，那么他将只被指控他已经承认的四起谋杀案。他同意了。汉森声称他杀害了17名女性，而不是调查人员根据他的地图怀疑的21人。他的受害者总是来自特德洛因区的弱势女性，她们的失踪很容易被当局忽视或无视。这种系统性的偏见确保了汉森在不用担心被捕的情况下保持他的杀戮狂潮。汉森喜欢在绑架的女性面前吹嘘自己，有时告诉她们自己是医生或律师。
He lured them with large amounts of money, knowing it would be difficult for them to refuse. Hansen tried to convince those questioning him that he wasn't the misogynist they thought he was, explaining that he only targeted women who he felt were inferior to him. Quote I'm not saying that I hate all women. I don't. Quite to the contrary. I guess in my own mind what I'm classifying is a good woman, not a prostitute. I'd do everything in my power, any way, shape or form, to do anything for her, and to see that no harm ever came to her. But I guess prostitutes are women I'm putting down as lower than myself. He assured his interrogators that he hadn't killed every woman he abducted. As long as they went along with what he wanted, he felt fine about letting them live.
他用巨额金钱诱惑她们，深知她们很难拒绝。汉森试图让审讯他的人相信他不是他们想象的那种厌女症患者，并解释说他只针对那些他认为不如自己的女性。引述：“我不是说我恨所有女人。我没有。恰恰相反。我想在我自己的心里，我所归类的是好女人，而不是妓女。我会竭尽全力，以任何方式、形状或形式，为她做任何事，并确保她绝不受伤害。但我想妓女是我认为比我自己地位低的女人。”他向审讯人员保证，他并没有杀死他绑架的每一个女人。只要她们顺从他的意愿，他觉得让她们活下去也无妨。
When they put up a fight or tried to flee, he felt the need to kill, explaining, I guess I wanted to control things. Even though Hansen couldn't remember many of his murder victims' names, the sites where they were buried were still fresh on his mind. He was flown to the areas he'd marked on his map, and according to the book Fair Game, Hansen became noticeably thrilled and exhilarated traversing his former hunting grounds. He triumphantly pointed out where he had left each victim and, quote, A couple of times he became so excited he dropped to his knees to dig in the snow with his hands, looking wide-eyed and with a smile on his flushed, pockmarked face. Those accompanying Hansen were disturbed and angered by his behavior. Promising themselves this would be the last time the killer would ever step foot in the Alaskan wilderness that he so clearly adored. They marked each and every gravesite, then waited patiently for spring so that they could start digging.
当她们反抗或试图逃跑时，他觉得有必要杀人，并解释说：“我想我想要控制一切。”尽管汉森记不清许多谋杀受害者的名字，但她们被埋葬的地点仍然清晰地印在他的脑海里。他被空运到他在地图上标记的区域，根据书《公平竞争》（Fair Game）记载，汉森在穿梭于他以前的狩猎场时变得明显兴奋和激昂。他得意洋洋地指出他把每个受害者留在了哪里，并引述：“有好几次他兴奋得跪倒在地，用双手在雪中挖着，睁大眼睛，在他那张充血、长满痘痕的脸上挂着微笑。”陪同汉森的人对他的行为感到不安和愤怒。他们向自己保证，这将是这个杀手最后一次踏上他显然深爱的阿拉斯加荒野。他们标记了每一个墓地，然后耐心地等待春天以便开始挖掘。
Tuesday, April 24, 1984 marked the first day of the search for Robert Hansen's remaining victims. With shovels in hand, groups of Alaska state troopers gathered around the spots marked on Hansen's map or pointed out by him directly and began digging. On that day, two bodies were found. 22-year-old Sue Luna was uncovered by a creek on the Kinnick River. 28-year-old Malay Larson was in a parking area downriver, a short distance from the old Kinnick Bridge. Over the next couple of days, a further two victims were recovered. The first was an unknown woman found by Horseshoe Lake, further inland and to the northwest of Kinnick River. Aged between 17 and 21 years old, she had been shot and stabbed.
1984年4月24日星期二，搜寻罗伯特·汉森剩余受害者的行动迎来了第一天。阿拉斯加州警手持铁锹，聚集在汉森地图上标记或他直接指出的地点周围，开始挖掘。那一天，发现了两具尸体。22岁的苏·卢娜在基尼克河的一条小溪旁被发掘出来。28岁的马拉·拉尔森在河下游的一个停车场，距离旧基尼克桥不远。在接下来的几天里，又找回了另外两名受害者。第一个是一名身份不明的女性，在基尼克河西北部更内陆的马蹄湖旁被发现。她年龄在17至21岁之间，曾遭枪击和刺伤。
She was white with brown hair and dressed in jeans, a sweater, a coat, scarf and tennis shoes. Hansen couldn't recall her name and despite efforts, investigators were unable to formally identify her. Like a clutner Annie, they named this victim after the area where she was found, Horseshoe Harriet. The second body was that of 24-year-old Angela Fadden. Scavenging animals had reduced her remains to just a jawbone. Three days later, 20-year-old Tammy Peterson was found on an island in the middle of the Kinnick River. 41-year-old Lisa Fertrell was next on May 9, located south of the old Kinnick Bridge. Just over one week later, 22-year-old Teresa Watson was found at Scenic Lake, 30 miles southwest of Anchorage. Bloodhounds were taken to the remaining gravesites pinpointed by Robert Hansen, but had no luck finding anything.
她是白人，留着棕色头发，穿着牛仔裤、毛衣、外套、围巾和网球鞋。汉森想不起她的名字，尽管付出了努力，调查人员仍无法正式确认她的身份。就像安妮·克鲁特纳一样，调查人员以发现她的地区将这位受害者命名为“马蹄哈丽特”。第二具尸体是24岁的安吉拉·法登。食腐动物将她的遗骸啃食得只剩下一块下颌骨。三天后，20岁的塔米·彼得森在基尼克河正中的一个岛上被发现。紧随其后的是5月9日发现的41岁的莉萨·弗特雷尔，位于旧基尼克桥以南。仅仅一周多后，22岁的特雷萨·沃森在安克雷奇西南30英里的风景湖被发现。搜救犬被带到罗伯特·汉森标出的其余墓地，但一无所获。
It was believed that if there were indeed bodies there at one point, they might have since been scavenged by animals or swept away by heavy rains in the sand and silt. In August the following year of 1985, an amateur pilot testing out his aircraft's new tires came into land along the sandbar spanning the Kinnick River. The area was no longer Robert Hansen's hunting ground, but his presence still remained. While there, the pilot discovered human remains. Two handmade rings found on the body led to an identification. It was missing Anchorage woman, 20-year-old DeLynn Frey. She would be known as Hansen's final victim, killed in April 1983, shortly after Paula Goulding. In the wake of Robert Hansen's crimes being publicly revealed, the media dubbed him the Butcher Baker, referencing his years of working as an unremarkable baker while secretly slaughtering women the entire time. The courtroom was packed when Hansen was sentenced for his crimes on Monday, February 27, 1984.
据信，如果那里曾经确实有尸体，它们可能后来已被动物啃食或被沙泥中的大雨冲走。第二年（1985年）8月，一名测试飞机新轮胎的业余飞行员在横跨基尼克河的沙洲旁降落。这个地方不再是罗伯特·汉森的狩猎场，但他的痕迹依然存在。在那里，飞行员发现了人类遗骸。在尸体上发现的两枚手工戒指帮助确认了身份。死者是失踪的安克雷奇20岁女性德林·弗雷。她被称为汉森的最后一名受害者，于1983年4月被杀，紧随宝拉·古尔丁之后。在罗伯特·汉森的罪行被公开曝光后，媒体给他起了个绰号叫“屠夫面包师”，指的是他多年来一直做着一个不起眼的面包师，同时却在暗中屠杀女性。1984年2月27日星期二，汉森因其罪行被判刑时，法庭座无虚席。
Friends and families of the victims made up a large proportion of the spectators. Survivor Cindy Paulson was also there. At no time did Hansen show any remorse for his actions. Assistant District Attorney Frank Rothschild described Hansen as an extreme aberration of a human being, then added, While he doesn't admit it, it's obvious from reading through and looking at where things started and where the women ended up, he hunted them down. He let them run a little bit, and then he enjoyed a little hunt, just like with his big game animals. He toyed with them, he wanted to scare them. He got a charge out of all of this. Rothschild was certain that Hansen was beyond rehabilitation, and requested he be given a life sentence and three separate 99-year terms for the four murders he was charged with. For the rape and abduction of Cindy Paulson, he asked for another 129 years. The presiding judge obliged, sentencing Robert Hansen to 461 years in prison, the maximum possible sentence available in Alaska for his crimes.
受害者的朋友和家属占了旁听席很大一部分。幸存者辛迪·保尔森也在场。汉森自始至终没有对自己的行为表现出任何悔意。助理地区检察官弗兰克·罗斯柴尔德将汉森描述为人性的极端畸变，接着补充道：“虽然他不承认，但从阅读和查看事情的起点以及女性们的最终结局来看，很明显他是在猎杀她们。他让她们跑一小会儿，然后他享受了一场小小的狩猎，就像对待他的大型猎物一样。他戏弄她们，他想吓唬她们。这一切让他感到兴奋。”罗斯柴尔德确信汉森已经不可救药，并请求判处他终身监禁以及因他被指控的四起谋杀案而判处三个独立的99年徒刑。对于强奸和绑架辛迪·保尔森的罪行，他要求再判处129年。主审法官同意了这一请求，判处罗伯特·汉森461年监禁，这是阿拉斯加对其罪行可判处的最高法定刑期。
He noted that even though Hansen's history was well known to authorities, he had been able to kill indiscriminately for years by targeting vulnerable victims. Quote, The court system has failed. If ever there was a case in which a man or defendant needed to be surveilled for the rest of his life, it is this gentleman here, and it's been known for many years. Here, we've turned a person loose several times, knowing he had the propensity for what he did. There's absolutely no excuse for it. I hope when we leave this courtroom today that I have to the best of my ability provided this man shall never walk the streets of America or any other place as a free man. Including a Clutner Annie, Joanna Messina, Sherry Morrow and Paula Goulding, a total of 11 of Robert Hansen's known murder victims have so far been recovered.
他指出，尽管当局对汉森的历史十分了解，但他通过锁定弱势受害者，多年来一直能够不加选择地杀人。“引述：司法系统失败了。如果说有一个案件需要对一个男人或被告进行终身监视，那就是眼前这位绅士，而且这已经广为人知多年了。在这里，我们明知一个人有这种行为倾向，却还是好几次把他放了出去。这绝对没有任何借口。我希望当我们今天离开这个法庭时，我已经尽我所能确保这个男人再也不会以自由人的身份踏上美国的街道或任何其他地方的土地。包括安妮·克鲁特纳、乔安娜·梅西纳、雪莉·莫罗和宝拉·古尔丁在内，罗伯特·汉森已知的谋杀受害者迄今为止共找回了11人。”
According to Hansen's confession, that still leaves six unaccounted for. While Hansen acknowledged that he had killed 23-year-old Andrea Altieri and 24-year-old Roxanne Eastland, they are two of the six victims that were never recovered. To this day, all their cases remain open. Investigators are certain that Hansen is responsible for more murders than he admitted to, given there were four markings on his map that he never addressed. One aligned with the location where 18-year-old Celia Beth Vanz Anton was found on Christmas Day 1971. She had disappeared days earlier after walking to a downtown store to buy a soda. Beth was stripped, bound, gagged and raped before being left in the McHugh Creek Recreation Area, where she froze to death. The crime has never been solved.
根据汉森的供词，这意味着还有6人下落不明。虽然汉森承认他杀害了23岁的安妮塔·阿尔蒂里和24岁的罗克珊·东斯兰，但她们是永远未被找回的6名受害者中的两人。直到今天，她们的案件全部仍然悬而未决。调查人员确信汉森犯下的谋杀案比他承认的还要多，因为他的地图上有四个标记他从未提及。其中一个与1971年圣诞节那天18岁的小采莉亚·贝思·范·安东被发现的地点吻合。她在几天前步行去市中心商店买苏打水后失踪。贝思在被剥光衣服、捆绑、堵嘴和强奸后，被扔在麦克休溪游憩区，在那里冻死。这起犯罪至今未破。
To many, Robert Hansen seems a likely suspect, especially as Beth's ordeal came mere days after Hansen attacked two other women, both of whom survived. Two marks made on the map along Resurrection Bay in the port city of Seward are also unaccounted for. It is believed one represents missing 17-year-old Megan Emmerich. Megan was a student at the Seward Skill Center and was last cited leaving the dormitory laundry room on Saturday July 7, 1973. She hasn't been seen or heard of since. Hansen admitted to being in Seward on the day Megan vanished, but denied crossing paths with her. He also said he was in Seward on Saturday July 5, 1975, when 22-year-old Mary Thill vanished from the city. Although Hansen also denied having any involvement in Mary's disappearance, it has speculated the second Seward-based asterisk hints at her burial location.
在许多人看来，罗伯特·汉森似乎是一个很有嫌疑的嫌疑人，特别是贝思的遭遇恰好发生在汉森袭击另外两名幸存女性几天之后。地图上沿港口城市苏厄德的复活湾制作的两个标记也下落不明。据信其中一个代表失踪的17岁女孩梅根·埃默里奇。梅根是苏厄德技能中心的学生，最后一次被看到是在1973年7月7日星期六离开宿舍洗衣房的时候。此后再也没有人见过或听到她的消息。汉森承认在梅根失踪当天去过苏厄德，但否认与她擦肩而过。他还说自己在1975年7月5日星期六22岁的玛丽·蒂尔在该市失踪时也在苏厄德。尽管汉森也否认自己与玛丽的失踪有任何牵连，但据推测第二个以苏厄德为基地的星号暗示了她的埋尸地点。
Both Megan Emmerich and Mary Thill's cases remain unsolved. Robert Hansen was incarcerated at a number of different penitentiaries before serving the majority of his sentence at a correctional center in Seward. In 2014, he was transferred back to Anchorage to be admitted to Alaska Regional Hospital as he was battling chronic illness. He died on August 21 of that year at the age of 75. By the time of his death, Hansen had admitted to carrying out 30 rapes and 17 murders over a 12-year span, though these numbers remained disputed. Upon learning of Hansen's death, Glenn Flothey told the Anchorage Daily News, On this day, we should only remember his many victims and all of their families, and my heart goes out to all of them. As far as Hansen is concerned, this world is better without him.
梅根·埃默里奇和玛丽·蒂尔的案件至今仍未侦破。罗伯特·汉森曾被关押在多所不同的监狱中，之后在苏厄德的一所惩教中心服完了大部分刑期。2014年，他被转回安克雷奇，由于身患慢性病而被送入阿拉斯加地区医院。他于当年8月21日去世，享年75岁。在他去世时，汉森承认在12年的时间里实施了30起强奸和17起谋杀，尽管这些数字仍存争议。得知汉森的死讯后，格伦·弗洛西告诉《安克雷奇每日新闻》：“在今天，我们应该只记住他的众多受害者和他们所有的家属，我的心与他们所有人同在。至于汉森，这个世界没有他会更好。”
In a 2019 interview for A&E's real crime blog, former Assistant District Attorney Frank Rothschild said that though some wished Hansen could have been given the death penalty, spending his final 30 years in prison had been a fitting end to his life. Here's a guy whose passion in life is going out into the wilderness and hunting the great Alaska wild. Instead of being able to do that, he was put in a cell with no view of anything, forget the mountains, with rancid air and horrific people around him. That, to me, is supreme punishment. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在2019年为A&E真实犯罪博客接受采访时，前助理地区检察官弗兰克·罗斯柴尔德表示，尽管有些人希望汉森被判处死刑，但在监狱里度过他最后的30年是他生命的恰当结局。“这是一个生活中的激情在于走进荒野并猎捕阿拉斯加伟大大自然的人。他非但没能做到这一点，反而被关进了一个什么风景也看不到的牢房里，别提什么群山了，周围只有恶臭的空气和可怕的人。对我来说，这就是至高无上的惩罚。”这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。